[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem truecrime Podcast von
Bild mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und ich
bin Stefan hallo zusammen
Stefan unser heutiger Fall bewegt mich
auch noch mehr als zehn Jahren noch sehr
und nicht nur deshalb weil diese
furchtbare Tat hier in meiner
Heimatstadt München passiert ist sondern
weil hier ein junger Mann gewaltsam aus
dem Leben gerissen wurde weil er nicht
zulassen wollte dass jemand seine
Verlobte schlecht behandelt und bis
heute lässt mich das Gefühl nicht los
das hätte genauso gut jedem von uns
passieren können es ist eine beinahe
unvorstellbare Tat am 28 Mai 2013 wird
der damals 31-Jährige
domeniculo auf seinem Heimweg von einem
Unbekannten erstochen nachdem dieser
dominikus Verlobte anspuckte dieser Fall
geht in die Kriminalgeschichte als Isa
Mord ein und bis heute ist der Täter
nicht gefasst doch bevor wir auf diesen
Abend des 28 Mai 2013 schauen wollen wir
erst einmal über das spätere Opfer
Domenico sprechen
Domenico ist gebürtiger Italiener seine
Angehörigen beschreiben ihn als ruhigen
sanften und religiösen Mann der
31-Jährige lebte bereits an vielen Orten
Europas zuletzt in München Domenico hat
hier einen guten Job der Italiener ist
it-ingenieur bei Airbus aber in die
bayerische Landeshauptstadt zog ihn
nicht die Arbeit sondern die Liebe
dominikus Partnerin ist auch Italienerin
im weiteren werden wir Sie Julia nennen
das ist nicht ihr richtiger Name doch
Julia möchte nicht dass man ihren echten
Namen in der Öffentlichkeit verwendet
das respektieren wir selbstverständlich
seit 2004 lebt die 28-Jährige bereits in
München um Sprachen zu studieren und als
Dolmetscherin zu arbeiten seit einigen
Wochen wohnen Domenico und Julia
gemeinsam in einer Wohnung in Bezirk
Haidhausen ihr Glück scheint perfekt
nachdem die beiden Italiener sich auch
noch verloben
[Musik]
der Abend des 28 Mai 2013 ist einer der
ersten warmen Sommerabende in München an
diesem Dienstag muss Julia lange
arbeiten Domenico ist bei einem
Deutschkurs danach trifft sich das junge
Paar am Gärtnerplatz für einen Drink
einer der beliebtesten und schönsten
Orte Münchens in der Mitte des Platzes
steht ein schalenbrunnen drumherum ist
eine Grünfläche angelegt auf den
gegenüberliegenden Seiten Reihen
sichtbares und Restaurants aneinander
das Wetter ist warm die Stadt pulsiert
das Leben ist schön um kurz vor zehn
tritt das Paar seinen Heimweg an für den
nächsten Tag steht etwas Großes an Julia
und Domenico fliegen in ihre Heimat
Italien um ihre Familien mit ihrer
Verlobung zu überraschen Julia und
Domenico fahren den Fahrradweg an der
ISA entlang ihr zu Hause ist auf der
anderen Seite des Flusses die Strecke
ist beliebt bei Radfahrern Joggern und
Hunde
auf der einen Seite fließt das
türkisfarbene Wasser der Isar auf der
anderen Seite fahren die Autos auf der
vierspurigen erhardstraße Julia fährt
ein Stück hinter ihrem Verlobten in der
Dunkelheit kommt ihr ein Mann entgegen
später wird sich die 28-Jährige
Italienerin nur an seinen schwarzen
langen Mantel und an seine Umhängetasche
erinnern völlig unerwartet spuckt der
Unbekannte Julia ins Gesicht und läuft
weiter als Julia Domenico einholt
berichtet sie ihm von dem Vorfall ihr
Verlobter dreht sich um und fährt in
meinem schwarzen langen Mantel hinterher
er will ihn zur Rede stellen es ist
dunkel der Radweg ist kaum beleuchtet
nur schämenhaft sieht Julia was zwischen
den beiden Männern passiert sie sieht
wie Domenico den unbekannten einholt und
wenig später eine Rangelei beginnt
plötzlich lässt der Unbekannte vom
Italiener ab und läuft weg das alles
geschieht binnen weniger Sekunden
Domenico
t und streckt Julia seinen Armen
entgegen er ist voller Blut danach sagt
der 31-Jährige auf dem Boden zusammen
der Unbekannte hat ihn mit mehreren
Messerstichen verletzt einer davon
trifft Domenicos Herz
so Mirko und hier unterbreche ich dich
mal kurz um über diese unvorstellbare
Situation zu sprechen da ist ein Mann
der seine Verlobte anspuckt einfach so
abwertender respektloser und
verächtlicher kann man einen Menschen
kaum behandeln aber ein wichtiger Punkt
dabei ist das ist keine physische Gewalt
heißt das Domenico hinterher fährt war
weder naiv noch lebensmüde er wollte
einfach nicht hinnehmen dass
irgendjemand seine Verlobte so behandelt
dass der Unbekannte ein Messer zückt und
zusticht damit rechnet ja wirklich
keiner das sehe ich ganz genauso und da
ist noch ein weiterer Punkt denn sowas
kann einfach jedem passieren man steht
für das gutes ein und gerät dabei an
einen wirklich schlechten und
grubbellosen Menschen
zurück an die Isar zurück zum Abend des
28 Mai 2013
Domenico liegt blutüberströmt am Boden
Giulia schreit um Hilfe und wählt den
Notruf schnell einen Passanten zum
Tatort und wollen dem Verletzten helfen
anfangs nehmen viele von ihnen an es
handelt sich um einen Fahrradunfall
deshalb läuft keiner dem Messerstecher
hinterher der Unbekannte kann sich sehen
ruhig vom Tatort entfernen und in der
Münchner Dunkelheit verschwinden 10
Minuten später sind die Einsatzkräfte am
Tatort Domenico wird schwer verletzt mit
einem Krankenwagen abtransportiert
Giulia darf nicht mit ins Krankenhaus
als einzige Zeugin muss sie gegenüber
den Ermittlern am Tatort Aussagen 45
Minuten später erreicht sie die
Nachricht der Mann mit dem sie den Rest
ihres Lebens verbringen wollte ist tot
ermordet von einem Unbekannten
Werbung
mein Name ist Dagmar Rosenfeld und ich
bin Robin Alexander und gemeinsam
besprechen wir im weltpodcast
Machtwechsel jeden Mittwoch das was das
politische Berlin bewegt wird die Union
ihren Neuanfang meistern wie verändert
eine Ampelkoalition Deutschland und
worum geht es aktuell in den
Hinterzimmern im Machtwechsel erfahren
Sie die Hintergründe zu den aktuellen
politischen Debatten hören sie rein
jeden Mittwoch ab 17 Uhr bei Welt und
überall wo es Podcasts gibt auf
Wiederhören
Werbung Ende
unmittelbar nach dominicus Tod wird die
SOKO Cornelius gegründet benannt ist
diese nach der Corneliusbrücke über die
der Täter wohl vom Tatort flüchtete in
Domenicus wohnten wird DNA
sichergestellt Domenicus DNA natürlich
aber eben auch fremde DNA Erbgut des
Mörders die Ermittler jagen die Probe
durch die Datenbanken der bayerischen
Polizei des BKA sogar mit ausländischen
Datensätzen wird sie abgeglichen
vergeblich die DNA des Täters ist nicht
aktenkundig aber durch die
sichergestellte DNA wissen die Ermittler
der Mörder hat sich verletzt als er
Domenico das Messer in den Körper rannte
die Mordkommission veröffentlicht
daraufhin in einem Ärzteblatt einen
Aufruf schreibt im Anschluss sogar Ärzte
direkt an und fragt ob sie eine
männliche Person mit einem
Verletzungsmuster behandelt haben
welches auf stumpfe oder Schafe Gewalt
zurückgeführt werden kann
aber auch dieser Ermittlungsansatz führt
nicht zur Aufklärung der Tat eine
weitere Spur da es neben Julia keine
weiteren Zeugen gibt werden die
Ermittler unter anderem aus welche
Handys zur Tatzeit in einer Funkzelle in
der Nähe des Tatorts eingeloggt waren
bis heute wurden mehr als 7.500
Handybesitzer befragt ihr könnt es euch
vorstellen auch diese Spur geht ins
Leere obwohl es natürlich eine Menge
Arbeit für die Polizei war und während
die SOKO Cornelius in München auf
Hochtouren ermittelt wird Domenico in
Italien beerdigt die Trauerfeier findet
in einer Kirche in seiner Heimatstadt
Potenza statt dominikus sagt ist von
weißen Rosen bedeckt davor steht ein
großes Foto des Italieners auf diesem
Held Domenico seinen Kopf leicht schräg
er lächelt beinahe schüchtern in die
Kamera seine Augen leuchten
unzählige Menschen wollen sich von
Domenico verabschieden und an seinem
Schicksal Anteil nehmen
die Kirche ist voll besetzt die die
nicht mehr in die Kirche passen stehen
draußen im Regen
[Musik]
zurück nach München zurück zu der Tat
und den Fragen die der Mordkommission
vermutlich den Schlaf rauben wie kann
Domenicus Mörder spurlos verschwinden wo
und vor allem wer ist er irgendjemand
muss doch etwas gesehen haben noch mal
zur Erinnerung julia konnte den Mörder
ihres Verlobten nur so beschreiben
männlich er trug eine Umhängetasche und
einen langen schwarzen Mantel
tatsächlich meldet sich einige Monate
nach dem verheerenden Maiabend ein
weiterer Zeuge bei der Polizei der
behauptet den Täter gesehen zu haben und
dass der Mantel Knöchel lang gewesen sei
letzteres bringt die Ermittler auf eine
neue Spur denn Stefan womit assoziierst
du Männer die lange schwarze Mäntel
tragen
da also für gewöhnlich ist das natürlich
erstmal nichts Unmögliches also
außergewöhnliches im Mai an einem blauen
Sommerabend aber da ist es vielleicht
schon eher ein Mode Assistent war
Priester kommen in Frage mit langen
Mänteln die tragen aber eine Messer mit
sich rum Heavy Metal-Szene oder so ja so
Gothic Fans vielleicht Männer aus dieser
fast nicht schwarze Mäntel schwarzes
Szene sowas durchaus möglich und wie
sich herausstellt fand zur Tatzeit ein
Konzert einer schwedischen Mittelband
namens dead by april statt
Veranstaltungsort die Muffathalle in
München nur wenige hundert Meter vom
Tatort an der Isar entfernt die
Ermittler machen beinahe alle
Konzertbesucher ausfindig und sprechen
mit Ihnen aber wieder vergeblich im
November ein halbes Jahr nach dem
brutalen Mord an Domenico wird die SOKO
Cornelius eingestellt der Isar Mord wird
zum Cold Case
Jahre später Wagen die Ermittler einen
neuen Versuch sie schicken die gefundene
DNA-Spur des Täters zur Uni Innsbruck
durch eine Analyse ermitteln Forscher
dass der Täter braune Augen und er helle
braune Haare hat seine Vorfahren stammen
unter anderem aus Osteuropa eine neue
Spur aber ganz ehrlich das gleich
natürlich einer Nadel im Heuhaufen im
Sommer 2021 trifft Bildreporter Karl
Keim Paolo und wikina in Italien
Domenicos Geschwister gegenüber Bild
berichtet Paolo von einem anonymen Tipp
den die Familie per Mail erhalten hat
anonym
mit einer anonym melderadresse wir haben
das dem Anwalt sofort weitergegeben
wir sollten nach einem Ex Mitglied einer
metal band suchen
an diesem Tag hat diese Person zwar
nicht gespielt
aber dieser anonyme Hinweisgeber sagt
dass diese Person trotzdem beim Konzert
war
was der Präsident es soll sich um einen
Kampfsportler handeln und derjenige soll
sehr wütend gewesen sein
wurde
diese Informationen hat jetzt auch die
Polizei also nach acht Jahren solche
genauen Angaben so detailliert
das ist für mich schon sehr überraschen
stammt die Nachricht von einem
Wichtigtuer einem Spinner oder einem
Insider war Domenicus Mörder doch auf
dem Konzert in der Muffathalle wer
begeht eine so furchtbare Tat wird
Domenicus Mörder jemals gefasst Fragen
auf die die Ermittler und dominikus
Familie und die anderen Angehörigen bis
heute Antworten suchen am 28 Mai 2013
wurde Domenicus Leben von einem
unbekannten Mann gewaltsam beendet
Giulias gemeinsame Zukunft mit ihrem
Verlobten wurde von jetzt auf gleich
zerstört Familie loruso verlor einen
Sohn und Bruder insgesamt sind die
Ermittler über 1000 Hinweisen
nachgegangen 400 Mal wurden Personen
überprüft nachdem sie andere anspuckten
in der Hoffnung Domenicus Mörder zu
finden von fast 6000 Personen wurden
Speichelproben entnommen um sie mit der
DNA von Dominikus Mörder abzugleichen
für Hinweise ist immer noch eine
Belohnung von 10000 € ausgelobt aber
alles vergeblich bisher
[Musik]
am 28 Mai dieses Jahres ist die Polizei
zurück am Tatort an der Isar die Sonne
scheint das Wasser der Isar funkelt im
Sonnenlicht auf der erhardstraße stauen
sich die Autos
neugierig schauen Jogger und
Spaziergänger zu den Beamten rüber
während sie den Ort wo Domenico vor 10
Jahren starb absperren dort stellen die
Polizisten jetzt ein vier Meter hohes
und 2 m breites Plakat auf es ist ein
überdimensional großes Foto von Domenico
der Italiener trägt eine Cappy mit einer
Hand Winkler in die Kamera sein Lächeln
ist so groß dass man seine Zähne sehen
kann neben Domenicus Foto prankt ein
Schriftzug
wer hat mich hier ermordet
[Musik]
das war unsere heutige Folge von Tatort
Deutschland als du irgendwas weißt was
den Ermittlern helfen könnte Domenicus
Mörder dazu finden wende dich bitte an
die Polizei in München Informationen
dazu findest du in den shonos unsere
Quellen
sternmagazin und unsere eigene
Berichterstattung Schnitt Lilly von der
Osten brustproduktion weight watch
Studios München vielen Dank dass ihr
heute wieder mit dabei wart und bis zum
nächsten Mal euer Mirko und euer Stefan